so a lot went in a bitcoin
on the frame bought gold and so
on and so on I knew but that
whiskey is sort of an asset that
increases in value every year if you
have the right brand or collect the right
bottles or the right
brands  Yes, you have to structure it now in such a way
that the general public
could benefit from the fact that you
need a whiskey currency.
Almost everyone can say, for example, I’m
now changing 1 € into a whiskey coin and it
’s 100% deposited with whiskey, yes there
is  many spectacular résumés
that begin with someone
earning a lot of money on the internet Andreas Tim's
résumé is definitely in the
top 3 on this spectacular list, he
wasn't a digital founder himself at the beginning,
but he was the banker who
sold the first German digital films  has over 200 pieces has
earned millions in commissions and
now after its transformation that
firstly I changed and secondly I am an
entrepreneur myself and that is to found a
whiskey distillery in which I am trying to
build the world's leading whiskey brand and to create a unicorn about it, it's
pretty crazy the
whole thing  listen to life Andreas is
very welcome to the OMR podcast with
Philipp Westermeier
cell phone yes hello hi I'm
a bit happy to say Andi we have
n't seen each other for a long time until today right
here in front of your door we are in
the country here from the  from your
distillery but you met
ten years ago in the digital scene you
were in the scene much earlier than
me what he used to be an investment banker um
but was born here in rüdenau so
before the circle is full we will go to the very
front if you come here then you have
studied exactly born in Miltenberg am
Main grew up here in the small village of Grünau
and then I did my USA
at high school and then at the
European Business School in the Rheingau
studied business informatics then
I became an investment banker
actually at Rothschild that was my
first station in Frankfurt merchess  and
acquisitions yes or focused on that
from the start then I came
to Warburgs in London which is now UBS that's where I
came up with the funnel Telecom
technician no the only one who
knew a bit about technology there in
the huge store and already
made huge deals back then  So that was before the
turn of the millennium
1996/97 E-Plus sold for 2.3
billion and so small to the in London
I was the team, so to speak, me and my
secretary the Essen Caproni a
heavyweight super secretary who
had worked day and night and
the presentations department right
yes i was the only one who
spoke german in this english
investment bank and keep young guy
i was 27 okay 26 27 years old or
young but that was also important because as a
young guy you could
understand the technology back then  such
a telecommunication for mobile communications,
um, Mannesmann
D2, yes, Vodafone, that was the
huge deal that then
fell out at UBS, so to speak, as the
end result, the largest merger
transactions in Europe of all time and
there I was right in the middle of it, that was
actually the ignition  is already an
income millionaire not quite yet because
as a young guy I earn and not
that much yes and London is very expensive
but
it was okay so anyway you’re
out of there at some point precisely because a
few buddies are still coming to me, so
they were also in investment banking
partly studied with me
we said Andi you are in such a
great segment and great deals and of course
we always do the multi-million dollar
deals not for the investment bank but how
would it be if we did the small and
medium-sized deals but
set up my own investment bank or an M&A company in
Frankfurt and then I did that,
I remember back then in the Caribbean,
I went on vacation for two weeks, smoked a lot of
weed, logged grids and got
any tattoos then I came back
and then to my friends  whether said
okay a ready here I'm giving
up my career now and we're going to open Corporate Finance Partners in
some garage in Frankfurt
yes that
's meanwhile and that was then for
many years it was just a
label in the industry exactly we're talking about
now so internet the noughties or
the early 10s then CFP was already
his first address for at least
for young German digital television
deals made I think for the first time
I sold the question to the dentist
you did exactly and at that time an
Axel Springer and public  Group, they
shared it, but
yes, that was a deal worth almost 300 million
and that was really
great business for us, yes, we were
actually the first here with market segment,
eh, no, we had
done larger ones before, even so in  Hamburg,
for example, around the corner from you Nico
Komma sounds like a
Chinese crèche but it goes back to the
founder Nikolai Mannig it was an
Internet service provider, so
just like Mobilcom or something like that, just
share it on the Internet and we have that
back then for 500 million antis delivered
buys in Italy that was 98.99
okay
more yes well so
done a lot with the Samba brothers Jamba for
example sold to very sign Xing
we sold a Burda brands for
friends on Ebay those were those
times  and so no that went
on and on yes the model is uhm you
always get 3% of the devolume in your role as m&r consulting yes not
always 3% for us the 3% was set that
was the business model no
retainers no expenses  it's all on
our own account but if it just
works then if I have 500 million
that makes 3% calculator 15 million
yes you have to pay a little tax
yes and uh you can read up there is
definitely what I'm asking now that they
total  in that time 300 deals made
right yes so if then in
some way i don't know it was
n't all that big yes well i'll say
everything that was over 100 million that
's maybe every
tenth every eighth deal or something
was still there  quite a lot of
financing rounds yes 5 million 10
million 20 million euros
to get money our business model
was also to look after the long-term
ne than there as it were more or less to fork an elevator
and work with them and
like a doctor ne a doctor of
trust  take care of them until they grow up
and the exit stops somewhere,
no, and after the exit we were
usually out because the companies that
bought them were of course
looked after by very large investment banks, yes,
but that’s more difficult one thing,
especially the founders  Ranze
come that they trust you so that
you get that you get
three percent, so to speak, that they
say to you okay we’ll give you that and baby
trust that you will find the best
buyer in the best that makes yes
sex in rock roll ne so yes exactly
don't drink coffee or cappuccino
and don't
run around like pinstripes and put on some kind of show,
but for us it was
also the fun factor, we had
a lot of parties and events and
we also grabbed the customers and
the important thing was always  You can also
get at them totally privately, no, because that
is every doctor must know his patient very
well and every patient should
change his doctor well, because the
medicine that he administers
may decide on survival and death,
and that's just how it is in the M&A business,
no me  my some people only marry
once in their lives some maybe
more than me i think i'm more
the one who gets married once but maybe that's how it is
if you have a company
no you only sell it once you
can't sell it a second time
very rarely  no but doing that and then
something again and again that's just
exhausting or there are even
stories about you that you
really always were on the side of the founders
and really fought there even
literally where is the anecdote where
you then together  nightlife
and then the founders from
your portfolio were attacked by bouncers
and then you attacked these
bouncers with whiskey or
wine buckets and overwhelmed
that's true that's that's from my
underground book nine and a half deals a
scene in Berlin in the club actually
also happened like that yes and I am
trained in karate and judo so with
brown and black belts and
I couldn’t rest then either
so I defended them then
actually
okay and there is
another anek that you can relate to  of the
Jamba deal you had to go out to eat a lot to stop
with all the wine in
your moderate potential buyers and then
it's always beaten that you
then took the personal trainer
with you as part of your team and
just always handed the food over to him
and didn't be rude  that
always eaten up and at some point
they then asked the guy here who opened
my food and then you have that is
your Personal Eater exactly so I made
the personal trainer and Personal
Lee who made it but it only
lasted about eight weeks and then two months
did he resign or somehow
gained seven or eight kilos and we were in a
really bad way like that, like in
that McDonald's film there and
yes I took it with me and
said there I you eat it now and
drink what I eat now  and have
to drink
for work and then you see that
the whole training is difficult,
so you can train as much as you
want, but you still don't get
slim because if you
take in 10,20,000 calories every day, then how
are you supposed to process it, so what
he then realized that Olli here he
's still in power today
his training very successful yes
what what was something like that in retrospect it's really hard to say the
the blatant deal from the whole one
but
a deal the me the me  it was really very
close that was ESL one also
turtle entertainment from cologne the guys
who make this gaming league are exactly who they are
in the end they are from
an ultra small super super
early stage startup they were the
very first in the market
to one  Unicorn grew and
actually became the market leader in the field of
eSports, yes, from Germany,
market leader Unicorn in this field and
uh, they were just really super
cool guys and we kind of
moved completely around the world Mom then
spent a lot of time in the USA and I
white in LA we once sat in
Hollywood in front of a billionaire who
wanted to invest there and so on and
he then made such a dirty offer
so it wasn't bad yes so
many would have thought oh okay
wow that's a great deal but we knew
yes what we have there qu here at the start and
then I got up and
freaked out and said don't [ __ ]
my unicorn who somehow started who
said this German Nazi recordings
but that's M&A
Advisor yes and and it's good that we
don't make the deal  did because in the end
they were actually sold for a billion,
to the
form of government of Saudi Arabia, so
very crazy yes, but well, of course they want
sports and so on,
many do and eSports is somehow,
uh, soon in the top  5 of all sports
yes, so the total value of the deals
I read in the research is supposed to
be 20 billion, so did you
sell the sum yes, that works, yes,
if you do the simple
math and you guessed it, then
add the 3% to it  I think it's
600 million, that's
kind of enough, that's enough for more life, that's
fine, as I said, you don't
always get 3%, you also have to pay taxes,
of course you have I had a team of 40
people, many employees, some great young
ones  Investment bankers and and deal
machines and I think they
definitely
had a lot of fun and earned well and so
no, because your success in the end you are
super smart
number type who then
think this through or or was that the
calendar on  At the beginning simply to
inspire people to get to know people to
bring people together what has at the beginning what how
can you be so good in this area
so fast it's always the mixture ne
the last one is very important because
nothing works without that but of course if
you don't know the numbers
I'd say
it's difficult to think rationally in a systematic way, no, so when you
study computer science, well, you have
analysis one analysis two yes linear
angebra
programming languages ​​C++ a sampler Kobol
Pascal and such [ __ ] and of course you have
all that in the back of your head yes
and  Were you recommended at some point or do
you have to? So we recommended one founder
to another man, let's go
to Andy, he makes a good deal,
yes, well, I think there have already been a lot of
recommendations, no, because
of course there has always been high competition in the industry
was and is if
you say a few other
agencies that you started at the time,
I mean Deutsche Bank, it was
too small for that now, so the segment,
yes, of course, many of them came from
Anglo-Saxon countries, but then later
a few also came into being  no, for
example, and to name them, um, there are
quite a few, well, most of them
then somehow resold, yes,
I also have a corporate finance
partner that then merged with the axle
and then boots were then
sold in the USA, so I have no idea 15
Billions with market Investment Bank
from St Louis USA, yes, there is always a
stop somewhere in the market, no,
but I think there is still
this gap in the market today, because for this
concept you have
to work very closely and intensively and personally with founders and with people  in
the area that somehow they do
n't really get it all right,
so there was the deal that
was mostly surprised by that there's the
legend you also sold DailyDeal
from vacation Fabian Heidemann to
Google at the time in the whole group
and there are those who
were actually a few days away from insolvency, so to speak, and then
you quickly found Google and
paid yourself 100 million, good,
that's right, of course, it was
always in the team, ne, as I said, I
also had really great people  who
worked for me or with me at CP
and
erm, yes,
we managed it, yes, there
were often situations where we did
business, they made just as much
loss as sales, but they
were positioned somewhere important,
with Daily Deal that was  so that in
English voice control this whole
segment the Daily Deal that's
actually the thing yes so tes a film
is also called
Scotch Tape because Scotch somehow
does it and so that for Google it was
somehow not a big not a huge deal
yes then new digits  To
pay an amount for it, the center
can switch it off, so to speak,
but you have to speculate on it,
it's a bit like playing poker
or going to the casino, it's like
going to the casino in Wiesbaden or Bad Homburg and and you say I
have it now  a suitcase full of money with me
and I'm going hardcore now I do
everything or nothing a few days for
insolvencies who can also say
we wait a little bit then
buy the rest of it so there was the
hottest one then, for example, my Alma
Marta the European Business School  It's
a private university, no, and it
always had financial difficulties because
it's a private university, then
we didn't get much government funding and um, we sold it,
no, that was with shares, yes, but
that was that, so we really
only had six  Weeks
time ne so that was really hardcore
and a very
interesting group from London was
interested in it and also made an offer
and recently made
global University Systems at Goldman
Sachs and so that was my favorite too, so
there was a lot too  Money from
Israel and so involved and
then they
did a few [ __ ] UPS on the very last Meder, so
they didn't want the property
our some little [ __ ] and
then we actually sold it
to the SRH Foundation in Heidelberg in the last few meters
this is
the foundation of which it emerged from the
pension funds of the Protestant churches
and is now a
top player in medicine and universities,
so they have a lot of
hospitals and clinics and also
a lot of academies from a few days
in the process  Yes, they
just had no idea they offered a million
less, he was peanuts and on
Friday we actually want to
fly to London and
notarize it, but then they
fooled around over the weekend and then
we said then you should call
the SRH on Sunday  Foundation and
ask if the notary of theirs
is cool on Monday and then we just sit down in
Zug to Heidelberg
at school it wasn't that much it
was 20 30 million no but it
's a top brand and it sort of has the
portfolio  complemented by the super and I
think what they are now doing with the European
Business School how you have
developed it I also only know
recently at the 50th anniversary celebration that
is sensational so that is a super
good shareholder and good port for
history that he  I also got to know
a lot of founders during this time
which founder
personality would say in retrospect
who is who or who is the crastest
person or who thinks
that is really difficult to say because because there are
always a lot of crass
and crazy and so no but  yes someone
who really touched my heart if
I may say so is my great
nephew Frederick Heigel who
is almost an adopted son for me anyway and
who has been busy ever since a
toddler is over the top but early
teens is into digital
estate management so what happens
when someone dies  with his whole IP
with the digital legacy no I mean
how often do you see that on Facebook
people who are no longer alive but
still have a profile floating around
or on Instagram or even more blatantly on
Tinder or otherwise
user wants okay user pictures is not yet
Unicorn or not in any way close by
is still a startup but
I believe that I firmly believe it
has a huge potential and
and we that makes it great and as I said
yes, I believe a lot of things
actually come from
this childlike movement these days  already
in our age range you
might not have been ignited until you were 25 or something like that
because you were so busy with school and studying
and all that [ __ ],
which
is sometimes pointless, yes,
but the kids nowadays take the covers off
a lot of it  and focus
on their stories, I would say
with a thumb,
maybe at the age of 15 or
earlier 12 or something like that yes and that's
actually quite interesting to take a
look at what's written there with this
whiskey or Diego Childs and stuff like that  yes, what is
coming is also just like that in the
startup and it is often like that
out of an impetus I want to
improve the world well that’s not at all
I want to make money now or
become a millionaire or build some unicorn
most people are interested
not at all yes because they just
live very simply and don't need that much
and like we used to, you
also said in an interview that the
goal at the time was already
to become a millionaire that was already
the aspiration yes it has  someone taught me at
high school in America yes,
then a teacher
told me that he says that if you
are not at least a millionaire then that is
[ __ ] yes then you don't need to
come to America anymore yes because it
sucks yes and then  I thought to myself okay
who's probably right I have to
come up with something no, but did it
work out, thank God, but although
you're not so aware of it, you
not only made the mediation
but at some point also
invested yourself, so your own fondant
at that time which  capital de I have wcvc.de today,
let's say a few hits from the
portfolio back then, among other things,
we were invested in ESL one, yes, we
brought up Brille 24, for example, then
sold essiloor as things like that, yes,
Deutsche Post intelligently, stories like that,
web track  very many many things
currently we also have a
few interesting companies in the portfolio, e.g. 123
driving school, the largest online banking
I have actually seen from you too, yes, yes, about
the year do
you want to be together with Steuer with Media
or Stone investors there
we also think that it has great potential.
Unicorn potential will take a
while but you
just have to be patient
so from 100
crowns investors
the deposit was somehow almost 40
million euros maybe because
it was smaller from Germany
very small actually yes but we have
really cool things yes and there are
somehow one or two
experiences that you can pass on from
the time so if you like that
has negotiated a lot if there is yes if
you somehow look at story books
and the Harvard concept such as
negotiation instructions and so but
something that you always heed what
you say somehow when you
hire someone new it’s always about
doing it now because in that  Life and
most of life doesn't come as
often as it does with you um what do you have to
say so the book I would
recommend from Harvard is called a
goshiading with the devil it was
written by a Harvard professor who
's really cool there  I
actually did a seminar in which and
it's really worth reading the thing, it's a tough one,
but my
principle is that
you have to know in every negotiation
what you really want, where you want to
go, no, and where do I say  sometimes the
minimum goal and the maximum goal
and then
a lot of dreaming and
believing in it and
going alternative ways that was always
the concept I have no idea if
the buyers are typically located in the USA
or private equity in front are
not only the appeal but  out of
the box, think in a completely different direction,
no, so we pull
potential buyers up, I mean it's
not that easy at all, there are
companies who have processes until you
somehow find a company there
that accommodates it like that  Sex trucks in
rocking scooters it's always partying
and just chatting with people having
fun
all over the world yes that just means
inviting the people now invited
and then there was a whole party team
at the end I had a penthouse in the
Westhafen in  I did
n't live in Frankfurt there but it was just parties instead, so for
six years non-stop until
the neighbors reported me to the police on
New Year's Eve, some cars were torched
with rockets as collateral damage,
then I had to
move out, so nothing worked anymore,
but I sold it  otherwise
the
scenario should really be imagined
somewhere now even if I
invited people to Mallorca Ibiza Club
Yacht so the whole number not so
Porsche so not so super high end
you don’t need that many resources
for it  just have to
be honest and cool yes you rent
some awesome location in Berlin e.g.
the Trust Club from Cookie and do the
trustparty and somehow make a funny
concept and somehow three blondes as
DJ and awesome Bölkstoff and cool people
and just invite cool people  and
then it's
okay, so it was always a
cool, honest number here, but I
mean it's amazing if it
works like that, then the big banks
can't do it too, look at
the people who do it,
okay you  do you think they have the talent
for partying yes or they are not allowed to do so
but with you at
some point you
made a trip
to the Andes yes and then you can
read about it or talk about it when you go
back down the mountain  when you came you were a
different person that's right the the
stories actually that
someone invited me to Ibiza
for a week and I
looked at the calendar and thought ah yeah
okay those are the flap openings
so when faded and thing  uh DJ they
know and everything I thought okay
fits well into the program and
then I went but then I
ended up in some kind of finca in the mountains
with some shamans and you
weren’t allowed to drink alcohol anymore
and only be vegan  fed there the whole
week and then
administered some herbal plants there a little that's how it
started and that was it was really
live changing and then I
met a buddy at the Golf Charity
Golf Tournament in Zurich who had a
similar experience to me
no longer recognized because he looked
completely different before, so he did
exactly, and, and, and, and then he said,
uh, somber to Peru the
week after next, whether I would like to
come along for two weeks and so, or
show me what and then I am  I
also said yes and then it went like that for
a while I
just made a few tips so
physically and so
in the end exactly exactly so in the end
the mine in the good old
hippie days what do they all have
Took LSD, no, and today
it's called Alaska or San Pedro
or something like that, I didn't know that
before because, to be honest, I
only drank and smoked quite a lot there
and
had fun, yes, but those were really
mine  opening
experiences
maybe before you forget there is
also one from the business punk so
the business magazine cover of
you was in Darth Vader costume on the
cover of the magazine that
cemented your legend a bit okay
that's crazy that's true
but I had one  blue label
lightsaber yes so from the Jedi
Knights that didn't really
fit together yes but that is also
a brand that really consciously built up
when Crazy Andy yes yes was a
bit crazy I was then I was
always ne whereby the
things sort of there  stop in Peru and have
already restructured a bit
and have grounded
no, I think that's decided I
'm listening now with all that stuff,
well, stop it, you
don't just throw things away or something, stopping
is always easier to talk about, but to get your
bearings  around and for me
it was just so that one thing I wanted to
settle down a bit
and have a family and children
and and and marry and so no that
's one thing and the other is
maybe just a
Building up a company not now
roast founders advising or or as how
they but really
independent back then I mean
that you said 600 million
are not quite okay that came about
and you also had 40 employees
it’s also annoying you get
already paid with the money but you can
imagine what
volume you had in your account
you could have said
build companies I’ll save that now I’m
not going to do any
Ayurveda or anything about
energy here with ST
Of course, Kilian also came about a
bit out of a hobby, so I
've always had an affinity for whiskey since I was
stationed in London,
so I always
flew to Scotland with my mates and
went to whiskey distilleries
and then started making
whiskeys too  So collecting single malts
and that was kind of a hobby for me, just
like others
collect stamps or
have cars or something like that, I had
that with whiskey, yes, and then
somehow the opportunity
arose, maybe my own whiskey
distillery  to build it up so sometimes that I just
jumped together and
then the question was do you do it
now somehow small homeopathically
actually like a hobby or do
you just do something real on top of it
something big something industrial is a
blatant turning point in your life i.e.
me  mine can all be
put together a bit by chance so on the one
hand this
life considerations apparently found in the mountains in
this phase Ibiza and Co and then
obviously the chance
to found such a distillery you can also
read about is new here in males so
then in the home village  could you buy an old
fashion factory or you were
asked if you couldn't help in some way,
so it can work
together somehow and then you sold your CFP,
you had already sold it, so
that was it then, or did you
deliberately sell it and give it away, it was
a merger with stocks merges but
also because you wanted to do something new
or because that's just a good
no no also with the idea of
not diversifying no
somewhere uh not giving up one thing completely
but also starting something new
no and that with me  with the
whiskey it was just a
huge, cool gap in the market here in
Germany
so it's not it's not a hobby or something like that, so
if you somehow
invest an eight-digit million amount uh equity
and and pull something up here like
St Kilian which maybe later  sometimes
in the schnapps area there is Jägermeister
or something like that, so that's the direction
we want to go in the long term
yes and what you want to
achieve you have to
think carefully beforehand because you can
of course say at 50 I enjoy
now  the fruits of life and and
only family and and a
bit of a stop tour through the world or
you just do another story like that too you
started that was in 2012 so that
was already more than 10 years 10 years
yes that was exactly it  from the idea
ne and and and and and implementation of the
company ne then came four years of
development work until 2016 then
production started or 16 are you then
having your first whiskey Whiskey has to mature
in barrels for at least three years
before you can call it whiskey
then it was already  2019 yes in May 2019 we
brought out the First Killian the
first whiskey and
then it felt like it went for two
years it went really cool
uphill and then Corona came along so
these huge to the whole world somehow in the
run down
illuminate the initial phase because  there is
also quite so you were often in
Ireland exactly
okay so you were often in Ireland and
did you there David Hayes I think his name is
David Heinz
Irish whiskey master brewer so
I imagine that you met and wanted
and that you met him  you
almost wanted to buy one, so
you left there and
normally people
somehow buy a bottle or something and
I don't leave before they
can buy all the time, so back then it was so
that everyone just got a bottle or
three bottles  bought three
bottles because one of them
you drink, you also drink one,
you collect it, so it goes into your collection
and you sell the third bottle,
when the value of the third bottle
has risen so much that it makes the purchase of the
whole  three bottles refinanced,
so you need a collection and
then I had a collection
of what do I know 2000 bottles of whiskey and
somehow I got a
bit bored and thought well
that's great if you buy a bottle of
whiskey for 200  € and now
it's
worth 500 euros, of course
someone will be happy, but if you
're a professional investor, you have to
scale it up somehow, you
also want to invest a lot more,
so I was interested in
maybe getting a
So you buy a barrel or barrels, so
to speak, because as an investment professional, you
immediately
had your glasses on when you visited the whiskey, you noticed the numbers are
investments, okay here,
one asset class is
an average of 10% every year, so you
can see the Scottish Whiskey
Investment Index  look at it over the
last 40 to 50 years, on average it has
risen by more than 10% every year yes,
inflation is not an issue now no ok then
I thought it would be good to
get 300 400 bottles out of that big barrel almost out of it
better than
if you only buy one bottle and then
I was just interested in
what almost costs and that was
incredibly difficult to
buy barrels from whiskey distillery so
I tried to
persuade them and no no no only at the
anniversary  or when it was founded or
if you're Prince Charles or Barack
Obama or then you almost get
frustrated and then I was in
Kiel Bagan that's
the oldest whiskey distillery in
the world outside of Dublin yes I really wanted to,
I said  there's my first barrel, no,
I won't leave until I almost have it and
then they
made such a fuss again and then I wanted to
speak to a manager and that was
David one well and he
only came on  next day it was
n't there at all next to the day i drove back from
Dublin there an hour the
met is at home but
how did i get the idea
that you could almost buy it
i say yes i saw better here
actually no  hear from Queen Elizabeth and
uh somehow Irish
prime minister and they have but that's
all marketing tell me it's
free that I'll pay for what's
no problem he's never
sold in almost his entire life we
first have to go to the accounting department to
calculate it  we
calculated around for two days and then I
almost grabbed mine, oh it was
n’t even 3000 euros at the time or so okay, so
3000€
could be 30,000 in a few years
but I’ll tell you exactly
now in your world that was
n’t much money  yes yes of course but my my my
thought was what if
you could have almost 100 or so instead of one
and then I just kept
looking for who could sell me more
barrels difficult and then
I was here at the Seehotel in Niedernberg
a great bartender was such a
whiskey bar and he says he through i have
a swedish whiskey here yes we
have a chef downstairs in the kitchen he comes
from sweden the chef for us and he
brought a swedish whiskey
mark myhra i have the bottle okay and
that's what he says you can buy better there,
so at the
weekend I flew to Sweden
to Stockholm and
drove up to geffler in the car and drove
up Mark Myra and said okay, how does that look because
you can
sell it here  they said too much you
want
that was a new experience when
i just took them with me they had these
30 liter barrels and their
business model was based on the fact that
they basically sell barrels to
swedish customers and at the time they had
already sold 15,000 barrels
what what  did you take it with you yes yes
they were
much more expensive in relative terms but it was worth it to me
and a good whiskey and
I thought the business model was
really cool no that everyone
gets their own water and their own
whisky  and that
inspired and motivated me a bit, no, and
when I later
founded Kilian, I said okay,
we have to incorporate that into the business model,
no, so not only sell the bottles,
but everyone can also
have their own whiskey and say so  Kilian
idea is really so the brand sounds
Irish or somehow different
Saxon but I think it was simply
a saint or a bishop
that came to the area from the island
yes sun so
you have to know that this is a
region  was it was extremely pagan yes
Franconian yes so Franconian Odenwald
Spessart so that was everything was
Christianized well your country was
Christian is here and so there were
already the monks and but here this
area yes well it was terrible yes
that was wild yes and  The Pope in Rome
had this problem back then, in the 8th
century AD,
that he wanted to counter-Christianize them
and there were basically only
Irish monks because they
were just kamikaze and he always
sent in battalions of Irish males here,
they  but they were all crucified and
burned on the sifting heap, so
they all flattened them
until Kilian and his buddies
came kolonnat and trottnan and they had something
with them that was the secret weapon that
was the aquavite, the water of
life, and they knew it  Irish
monks in their monasteries who
already knew how to make whiskey distillate from barley, so to speak, from
malt
aquavite whiskey that's basically the same
yes and they did, they went upstairs
and then gave a bull from the Pope
saying okay we're going to
Würzburg  Franconia and we
Christianize the guys and then they
just came to the court of
King Großberg and his Queen
Gailana and he says the hair again,
any guys from Ireland who
want to Christianize us, get on a
pile of we're having a
little party now  eat a nice meal
and then we burn them as a
show effect yes and they said
stop stop wait a minute we have something
with us here the aquavite try it
yes and then the only one who
wanted to try it was gailana
so the woman from  König Großberg and she
was actually always known for
being very grumpy and a
bit dogged and not so relaxed
and then she drank the aquavita
and suddenly a few minutes
later 10 minutes later she
became very relaxed and then started to close
dance like that get dances performed
Würzburg yes that is all
Christian tradition yes and there
you have the name because I was inspired by
this exactly they are around here
they have become best friends
Kilian Kolonnaden with King Großberg
and he said you can  Christianize as much
as you want, the main thing is that
you need a lot of aquavite and
give us that to drink and then
those up here are ne and they were just around here
in Amorbach
here in Michelstadt everywhere in the
Odenwald and they have all that
Christianized so and they were
Irish monks who
brought the aquavita to Franconia
together with Christianity and
then a thousand years later the
Irish master distiller the David F1
yes from Dublin then friends the
most successful master of the dela of all
times ever  in Ireland
and explains to us how to
build a great whiskey distillery here and how to
produce whiskey you have to say yes
and how does it start so you
got this guy with the
Irish know-how there was this former
fashion factory here, so to speak  it was written
by chance that he bought it yes i
assume not a lot of money now that because
everything here has run down a bit it
cost a million that was
manageable and then you somehow
invested eight-figure money
so we are also talking 10 20 30 or something like that
yeah something like that
and then it started with the fact that we
simply built here produced
yes we had to he knew how to set
everything up here and of course had
all the contacts to the Equipment
Manufactures you have now
seen our two copper pot styles from
forsais, for example, who have them  normally a
delivery time of 8 to 9 years that's
like if you order ten Ferraris
yes you won't get them
overnight and if you don't have any contacts
you won't get them at all and thanks to David
we got all of that in two years
yes  because he
was a business partner of all these
top manufacturers for 40 years and
of course he also knew how my distillery was
assembled because he had helped
build up the whole whiskey empire for the teeling for the already tealing so the teeling family in Dublin and
uh he  david is an engineer
dublin engineering studying but
mba very early on and super
smart guy and he told me
watch out i have been working all my
life for john also
an ex investment banker and he
raised that when i  you Germans here
so you a whiskey the stillerie Bau
then there's a requirement I want to
implement everything I've learned over the 40 years here and that
will cost a lot of money no because that
's not standard now it's the solution,
it's just ultra  high end
quality and I don't want to do it again
as a retirement project here myself
than when David Heinz yes and
yes we had a
campfire and a whiskey club here and then
we had a tasting with 20 whiskey
friends males  Fans and stuff and
then we really got completely
stoned the david just
presented grenades of whiskeys 2030 40
year old whiskeys and most of them
completely quit after the 15 and 20 whiskey
in the end there was only
david and me and at some point I am  i
fainted and i
woke up early at dawn at my fun campfire and no one was
there and david was gone too then
i asked my uncle where
are the david one that said he is
somehow at 9 o'clock with him  Drove the car
to Frankfurt and
flew away saying yes you had at least three
problems or four years feeling yes but it
doesn't matter he can take it no
and two weeks later I could
n't really remember anything
but it was a great evening and
the whiskey club people were all flashed
and they've never
experienced anything like that, such whiskeys, such a master
distiller, and then two weeks
later, my assistant calls me to
the can and says you ordered something like that
in Scotland, I say like no,
what, I have no idea, there are
lots of bills coming here  purely I say
was what, for example yes down payment
for two coppers still twice 480000
pounds
now I say and what else she
is already calculator clear clack clack
clack we already have 2.5
million euros on the clock I'll say
yes and who  ordered all that crap
that said a David F1 and I say
which company because Tümmler GmbH say I
don't even exist say you no you
founded one there no not that I
know okay very strange yes I couldn't
remember anything like that
It dawned on me a bit and then
I tried all day
to reach David and then in the evening
he finally called me back I wanted to
ask him what's going on what kind of
[ __ ] is this here and then
he says cell phone I have it
did it exactly as we discussed it around the campfire
at dawn yes I
didn’t even
fly back to Dublin I rebooked a flight I went
straight up
to Edinburgh I placed all the equipment
orders and the whole soul
ordered everything running and we
build it  largest whiskey single mall
whiskey distillery on the continent
everything totally awesome and and and I so yes
what does all the fun cost me yes he has
not made a business plan up to now yes
we would have to catch up on that so
the lot went so it was really really
blatant  on
the one hand you wanted to
do something else in your life and then
it came like this more or less you
found each other can you describe it like that
you can say it is actually
quite sophisticated so if
you hear it like that now you have
me too  just now but before that there
are
two business models namely
to produce and
sell whiskey as normal but at the same time to
produce whiskey to put it in stock
and, so to speak, to have a
bit of Bitcoin for yourself hoping that it would
then be easy  over time
building a brand will gain more value properly so
the chick to
go into the food retail business and
you also say to me in the end my
role model is Jägermeister who make
sales of around 1.21.3 billion euros are
on the road worldwide that can  you do
n't necessarily succeed with whiskey, but you
can get in the right direction,
yes, you can at least
be extremely successful in the whiskey sector
if you look around here a little bit,
then you get a statistic
that hangs here
in the factory and says that
you have your annual output  currently about two and a half
thousand barrels, if you think about it now, the
retail value of the barrel is
10,000, yes, ten, or if it
has matured longer, maybe even 20,000,
because that's more than what you
wanted to buy back then because it's high,
because the brand is higher quality  yes, if
you then fill the bottles
and then convert them into bottles,
the retail value is of course
relatively higher, no, that means here we are
talking about an
annual value of production that takes place in the city
in the range of you can easily
calculate there  times 10,000 times 200,000 here
we are at something like 50 million
yes it can be yes so the
direction is so that is St Kilian
is definitely
a company that will sooner or
later become a unicorn, so to put it
in tech jargon
unicorn  because sales or
because what is the strength driver so
the sale of the bottles or so
one thing is of course it burns no well
San Kilian since 2019 we have
won over 200 gold double gold medals
so we
regularly take part in all
important international competitions no well
not only Bundesliga but Europe
league champions league global league
and we are incredibly successful there, we
are already very well known there
and and we have
a lot of awards and high
quality levels and that is of course
incredibly important for the brand, the second
is you have an operative  right
exactly that has to make sales sell
bottles sell barrels
bring visitors here and
we're still relatively early stage yes,
at the moment we're
actually only in Germany a little bit of
Austria and Switzerland we
sold and had a good 200,000 bottles last year  around 20,000
visitors 200,000 bottles actually
maybe around 10,000 almost owners 1000 almost
owners yes it is it is still
a bit early stage yes but it will
now be on this nato site here in the
Hunsrück no what is
definitely a good new position yes
now  Yes, yes, that's exactly it,
all the goods have to be insured, and and
and with the insurance you then do
an exercise of what happens in the
worst-case scenario and also an inventory
and judithiums and such and that's that, there
's the actual system
now  a bit where can I
store all that stuff and there
is not enough space here in this former fashion factory
and then you said
man, it was a natural support point,
we can knock right there
there were 120 concrete bunkers, big concrete
bunkers where  So in the past ammunition
was stored like that and that has been
shut down for a long time and it has optimal
storage conditions for the whiskey and B
fits in there like 50 60 70,000 whiskey barrels
and there are already some there
exactly so it’s always good  yes,
we ammunition that now,
so to speak, not just with
cartridges or Pershing rockets,
but with whiskey, yes, but some of these are
your own and
some of the customers who invite you to your whiskey, their
own, but the
customer barrels, as I said, there are also barrels
about 1000 customer barrels already no that
's normal
no the whiskey bunker that's a
different concept that's actually
the second concept one is
you sell
whiskey bottles or casks as a company or you have
visitors here and with that you kind of make
sales or business that  one is
the operative business is another is yes
I'm an investment banker and I
invest the whiskey myself but a
good concept is always when
others also join in or
let others participate and that's
the next level, so to speak, no
that  it's like you put 5,600 whiskey
barrels in the bunker and say
that's an investment now and
anyone can pay in and then you buy one and
say exactly I want to invest 10,000 or
50 or 100,000 € and then
I don't have much data on it  such
a whole whiskey so in the end again
which chapters before just not into
whiskey exactly and you also want to
know but from various
areas so mostly your own
first but if that's not enough yes
if the concept gets too big you could also
whiskey
talk about other distillers and the
third stage is there I now also had
a one the very first presentation
was here in the Industry Club the second
presentation was in the Steigenberger Hotel
in Frankfurt at the Investment Punk Gerald
we hear I don’t know from Austria
crazy guy  could you
lie down too, yeah cool guy for sure
and and he just had a conference with all his
crypto investors
there I presented it and
now I’ll be back at the Airport Club
in Frankfurt with the number the
idea is actually one
So making whiskey currency is a
cryptocurrency which, like before Knox,
is not backed with gold but
is backed with whiskey, so the 100%
asset backs up with an annual
quasi-guaranteed increase in value, no,
and where you basically don’t have a down time,
but always actually have one  constant
development but a lot is falling off how
much whiskey is because in the end the
product itself and how much is the
brand I mean that say
the product from the stores is
worth nothing if you were to say
the brand is bad and
you would  prove that you're there I know in
everywhere then that would be right away
somehow you just have to have a super
cool marker
nothing okay without the brand
nothing works but we are currently actually
one of the top ten whiskey distillers as far as the run raid from the awards is concerned  in
the world and this
brand says exactly so that's now was
for example recently the World
Whiskey Awards were in London that's just
like the global Champions League yes and
we got eleven gold medals with our whiskeys that's
sensational
that's that  and now we've been
invited
again, somewhere else where they
said you have to arrive in three
days because it's unbelievable, you
cleared everything, so
we're
really great in terms of quality and standing, but we still have to in the end
that
also shows that to normal people somehow, so they look
at the places, but you also have to go
to the trade, so we now also sell
through Rewe or Edeka, so you're
really as classic as a
food
startup in the trade and  you say, man, it
wasn't even a bit here, so
we're mostly in the
specialist trade, no, at the whiskey stores
and so on and we sell directly, but we're
going now too, or we've also
started
going into the premium LH with brands with a second stomach, no we  have,
for example, stomach-licensed like Bud
Spencer and Terence Hill or also
some heavy metal bands like Judith
Priest and Grave Digger do quasi
wieskis under their im and bring them
to the Premium LH and become better known
ne you have 15,000
Rewe and Edeka in Germany  Markets and if we
're in there everywhere then there are
two 3000 people in the shop every day
that's a difference to a
normal whiskey shop or something like that yes and
you don't have such a large selection and
that's kind of our strategy
that we're there  just go in so that we
become better known but in the
end everyone comes back to the ST
Kilian brand or the stilion
brand and there are also an
incredible number of collectors there are an
incredible number of people who
collect whiskey and if you then
have a limited edition  we sell a bottle like that
for maybe €50, then it
's
a lot higher on the secondary market, sometimes €100
sometimes €300 exactly, so if you
go to Ebay and his Kilian
has one, that's actually a good
indicator of where we stand, no
currently and then what's up Trader there
are a number of platform wiki
different platforms where you
can trade things like that but ebay is
actually the scaling
under the funnel so
you've now taken Bud Spencer
and Terence Hill not just on St kilian approaches so that's where
you pay  then license rights right to to these
people or to the family who see the
descendants of Bud Spencer and
and to Terence Hill so to
Mario Girotti
came up to us really here
we thought about we also want to
make a blended whiskey so not  only
a purebred Sankt Kilian Whiskey,
but we are also working again in Ireland
with David Heinz from
the gray norwand Distillery and we
just want to make a product that
can be used more widely, ne where you
can really stand in every Rewe and Edeka but what  I also spin quickly,
no, if I put a bottle of San
Kilian in there, no matter how good it
is and how many 100 gold medals it
won, maybe
nobody knows and then it won’t be
bought that easily either, but if you put a bottle of
whiskey in there  where Bud Spencer
and Terence Hill is on it that
maybe every second third fourth knows
and says oh I always wanted to have a whiskey like that
but that means they
found you they have so you did
n't call them now somehow
and says man I have one  idea
but they were interested in whiskey
and looked around and then they
called
you, you actually approached us through the
licensing department of Bavaria
Film and said we were looking for
a whiskey distillery that would implement it with us
and they apparently
already have it  talked to several people and they
all thought it was somehow uncool or
and we said within five
minutes let's go yes
[laughter]
Terence Hill whiskey are you now selling
in the hundred thousand range yes
really yes
okay and that means a nice
additional income if he gets something there
he gets a
share of the turnover for that, no, a license
like that is measured in the turnover
and and minimum
guaranteed return, which is just how the
license service is made, also with
the rock bands with Judas Priest or something like that,
it works exactly like that,
they are in the end  also
approached us about the
management, so to speak, and said they were
looking for someone who could do something like that,
they heard from us that we
are innovative there and and and so we
came up with the idea that we are
doing a multi-branch strategy, no
that  would be ST Kilian is ultra high and
premium the core brand but to
broaden your horizons
you of course also work with blended
whiskey and so on Bud Spencer Terence Hill
Hollywood Stars yeah eh or with heavy
metal rock bands ne and the latest thing
we're putting on this year  I can
also talk a bit out of the
sewing box is we we will
cooperate with the or we will cooperate so the
ink is dry with the with the
Bavarian royal family with the
Wittelsbach family so with the descendants
of King Ludwig or Neuschwanstein
Nymphenburger
Porzellan Kaltenberger
Ritterfestspiele and see  so on and so
on yes well that is that they ended
up ruling
the kingdom of Bavaria as Bavarian kings for 800 years
and yes they came up to us
and
said hey that would be cool
if we did something together and that
it was like a godsend for us because
of course we are also looking for
something really awesome exclusive that you
can also market to Asia, for example to Japan to South Korea Hong Kong
Singapore and so na where where really
the ultra high end collectors  what what do
you think you can do for a few years
with the retail business and not with the
storage and and with the retail
business what can you earn with it
in terms of sales oh that's hard to say yes of
course it will be
incredibly difficult to
get hold of a Jägermeister like that  that's
two, three generations and such, but
you can already make 40-50 million euros in
sales with a cross-marchining
of 70% in the business, yes, that's like
software, that's one-to-one, like
how a software company works  yes
but of course you have to build a good
foundation the brand is very
important and you mustn't forget it
's just a production company yes
you were producing you have to
store it there that's eh works
here but in your company currently
maybe 30  40 fte it's
highly automated but that's the
biggest employer here in town at least
that's already
in the region but in the village yes and
you still want
to finance everything yourself or not
get it in front of the person that does it
you can do everything  That's right,
yes, so everything is self-financed and
there is a bit of outside capital,
a few subsidies, a bit of KfW, just
in the mix, but that's all totally
healthy and which model is
the stronger in the end, I mean when you
say storage  already
bottles or solid worth more than
100 million, that's a
lot of money if you or
the trading business will be fuller, let's
say the
bottle sales business, well I think it
's a combination out there, but
of course the bigger the warehouse gets  the more
valuable the warehouse becomes in the end
no and I mean the value
always materializes only with a deal no, so
to speak, but in this case it is
not planned at all no so it's not like
I want to sell the company now
or list it on the stock exchange  wants but
that's actually a classic
model,
medium-sized family business model, well,
where does someone have the
reasons for grandpa and then
at some point it goes on to the children and to
the grandchildren
that he could go in this direction yes
and um it has also been shown that
let me say in Germany at least
many of these medium-sized
companies are very strong ne so
behind champions
world market leaders yes we have around the
corner, for example in companies the
wika
that is the largest manufacturer of pressure gauges
in the world billion
companies ne
that belongs to one type so that is  but
if you say you're going to make the
family-owned unicorn thing then
here's that's being created by me tumblr
sure but you don't realize it no
so that's
you have to invest again and
again and keep doing it and so
clearly but in the end  is
n't that what makes it so
tell me a basic idea that's still slumbering here is
we now have this thing with
inflation no I said 10 years ago
inflation oh oops
watch out for the build up no so a lot in
a bitcoin others
bought gold and so on and so on
I knew but that whiskey
is an asset that increases in value every year
if you have the right brand
or collect the right bottles
or have the right brands yes and
that  now to structure it in such a way that the
general public could benefit from it, so that
you build a whiskey currency,
that you say okay, you have no
idea, ten bunkers with so and so much
whiskey and togo nice, that makes a
cryptocurrency out of it, you can
enter whiskey coin  or Whiskey coin.de
or something like that, where you end up there everything is already happening
and and and
then almost everyone can say, for example,
I will now change one euro into
a whiskey coin and it is 100%
deposited with whiskey and in  the base
value 1 euro it is actually the
only spirit where you
could do that I mean why because whiskey has
the world market share of
40%, i.e. 40% of all spirits
that are drunk worldwide are whiskey then
nothing comes for a long time then vodka comes
maybe with 20  %
then comes around with 8% with
four and a half percent schnapps with percent
so
why is it the English had
this Commonwealth yes and they had
the Scots and theirs with them and
then after India Australia
New Zealand USA Canada Asia around everywhere
and then everyone has  I said okay I do
n't drink any fruit schnapps anymore I do
n't want any more rice schnapps I don't want that anymore even the French do
n't drink cognac anymore they
all bring whiskey why yes because a single
malt that's just a great thing no you
can then hold
Mac allen  or a wolfsburn or a
Glen Scott yes and so and so age and that's that
's just for everyone who is now writing down pants
from the lower class to the
middle class is that the
drink well so if you're in China now
and give your buddy
some present  Chinese rice liquor
everyone has that but if you give the awesome
single mall I don’t know 18-
year-old Art BAG or you have
something really awesome whiskey made in
Germany from St Kilian Limited Edition
or
Judas Priest anniversary bottle or
something that’s just something different  it
also has something to do with
social status and with
valu and things like that, there are actually
listed distilleries in Ireland, so
I mean the biggest the
world market leaders in this area
probably come from Ireland or
are just there are a few
spirits companies worldwide who have
just bought a lot of whiskey distilleries
collected the CEO e.g.
or Penno Ricard uh sandory in Japan
USA there are Brown forms Jack
Daniels is one of them
because you just brought them off the market
if you hear it like that then there are a
whole series in Germany no small ones  There
was no whisky, but they deliver it here,
so I mean that's not
confirmed, that's clear, but that
's just Scottish whiskey or
Irish whiskey,
of course we compete with those from the
quality standards, that's clear, so
the ST Kilian will not be
with that  Schnapsbrenner Gentian or something like that
compared, but ST Kilian is
already compared to your favorite
whiskey from Scotland or Ireland or
somewhere else, but it is German
whiskey because it is made here
or all the additives are also
made here, so they outweigh
the substances, so that  Miles comes
from Franconia, so from the
Weiermann company in Bamberg, mostly, um,
of course, the barrels come from all over the world,
but for the brand, that's
important for the brand, but it doesn't matter for the product,
it's not like crying
when you say it is  now
French wine it also tastes
different than Italian wine or
Californian wine so in the
end it doesn't
matter where it's made from
no if you dent it then we're
actually from the
manufacturing process and the
way we make whiskey  we
a classic Scottish how is it
celery but on German soil and of
course with the resources mainly
from Germany but partly also
the story is actually true that you know
your whiskey barrels here with such
rock music day and night because
then the whiskey gets better due to
this vibration
So this experiment
actually exists, yes, it is interesting that you
mention it, but
we didn't invent it, yes, it's
a couple of freaks from the USA who are doing it,
I think more telegra, because they also have a
little bit of a hand in it,
but we have a completely different project
started what is just as interesting,
namely we sat together at the whiskey
beforehand, tasted a few whiskeys
and then
Mario, my master distiller, said yes, we
had to
think of something new and so and then I
said well we could just come
almost bury a whiskey like that in my
garden, yes, we'll
just dig a hole
two meters deep and throw a
full barrel of whiskey in there, put the earth
back on it and then we'll come
back after three years and see what's there
and then of course it worked  the bets on in
the round at the whiskey fire what
happens then, yes, whether the barrel
is still there, whether the whiskey has run out, whether
any worms, maggots, moles
have attacked it and so on and we
then googled we then
researched everything but we couldn't do anything
also couldn't find anything about it
just a week later they came with
the excavator and then dug ten holes
in my garden and
threw a few barrels in there
oh then we got them out again three years later
and that was the
sankilian earth ripening
[  Laughter]
It's so normal and whiskey
needs oxygen, no, whiskey
almost needs oxygen for
oxidation, no, it goes through these
mini cracks in those almost up there, this
micro-joke goes through, so that's without
oxygen because there's nothing in the ground
but no oxygen then we
tried this whisky,
so we tried it out, so the color of the skirt was
good, it
tasted like whiskey or had
really fantastic floral earthy great
notes so really really awesome
and the alcohol content had
also been greatly reduced from
63  .5% down to a good 40 percent yes, it
went down really well,
something happened there and then
we found each other, so we found out
that there was a kind of diffusion
taking place, an exchange of
liquids through these micro-cracks
in the almost  up there that means
water or moisture or
liquid from the lower soil
penetrates into the water and
alcohol and liquid from what goes
out into the soil and what was also
interesting is it doesn’t have a
single worm or maggot or
mole or  I don't know what else is
going on two meters below, yes, he almost dared to try the whiskey,
nothing,
that told me again that
humans are the only crazy species,
intelligent species on earth, yes,
the ones that constantly deal with whiskey  and and
ethanol and the other
critters there all make a big berth around the outside
but regardless of this
earth ripening was immediately sold out 99 euros
the bottle everyone wanted one so it
's
super tasty like that and then this band
Grave Digger came up to us ne Grave Digger
means yes there were grave diggers yes so no
said okay we do a
really fat trip with them and then
we just started drinking a little
too much whiskey again a bit crazy
with the Axel Ritt from Grave
Digger and his buddies there yes and then
it just came about that we have now created
a kind of cemetery in Bunker City, so you
have a large
area, 80 hectares, with forest and
fog, 500 meters
high in the high Odenwald, no, and then
we went to a Sackbauer, so to speak, in
Großheubach you have  said you have to give us
a couple of coffins Rooms for whiskey Barrels of
whiskey almost fit in and then
we buried 40 barrels in
coffins two meters deep and
made wooden crosses over them that say
what kind of thing is almost buried there
and that's the idea  the Grave Digger
the band, so to speak, at some point is
of course a bit of diligent work
with our warehouse people so
that they come in some night and
fog action with good ones and
dig out the barrels of the cream and we
then fill the bottles again
as earth ripening and  The end of
this story is that at
some point we got a call from the
University of Oxford, so there was
Mario Rudolf on the phone and our
master distiller then called me,
[ __ ], I have the University
of Oxford somewhere and the partner  on
the cheek they now want to
research and explore with doctoral theses
how the
earth barrel aging works what can I do
it or what should
I say yes I say that I have no idea I mean we just
tied with me
relatively almost threw whiskey in there
he de on it and
got us out again three years later
yes what more do you want to
say about it no but the ones from
Scotland got so much attention
what we do here that is
up to university circles who
asked themselves there is  somehow
more behind it but it was really just
a whiskey
but you can also do that with the sound system
that's also cool that's there
too but you can't
taste it or
I don't know it I do think that
the sound is something too  makes a difference yes
well I can imagine that that
definitely does something to
the whiskey I just don't know whether
Beethoven or Mozart is good now or whether you
'll play better like Metal or Metallica afterwards I'm overwhelmed but
it's a  cool experiment you've
actually thought about it from time to time in the last few years
what you missed,
I mean
you still think a lot about monetary things,
so not that you
've stopped thinking about
money or the economic structure after your transformation
probably the most active phase of the
digital start-up and selling and very
high ratings and even IPOs
you let everything go, so to speak, now
for this new business because the
last five six years
it started with German digital television
and that’s all much bigger and there
you were  actually already out that's
the new decision you sometimes
should make the digital world 50 years old
because then I could have
done it if a gigantic
I think what was important for me
was learning what I do in the MMA
business  and adventure capital business
in order to implement that in this venture
and then it's often
like that now we're coming back a
bit to the tex scene that
that's one of the main problems for the
founders or for these entrepreneurs
in the end  that he has to share everything
no so it’s already happening you do
n’t have one reason you have two
or three or five then one is
more active the other is less active at the
beginning everyone is active then
one is eliminated but still has shares no  let's
start then all the rounds
of financing come yes um
ABCD the cat is sitting in the snow at the
end you still have 3% of your
unicorn yes that's not bad no 3%
of a unicorn is cool no but
I really often have that from alpha
to  Omega witnessed and saw that there
was often somewhere or a personality or a small team that did it
and everyone else was there,
of course, they invested or gave
money or did something about it or something like
that, but that's all replaceable,
so you could have too  can
even replace equity with debt capital in extreme cases
yes,
which is of course incredibly difficult in Germany
yes and that
hurt my heart a bit no
because I would have liked to
see a founder who then sold somewhere in the Unicorn
he said okay
that's me, that's all, i've done it,
yes, and instead of leaving one or two
or three percent left over, at the
end you say you've
created more value with the whiskey and
because it also belongs to you alone as a 100%
investor  than you could have
been there now with deals and at some point
exactly so the value creation
here is much much higher that one
or the other today
is felt today is falling over and its for
me it's selling what you want to
get no idea  you
would have to invite Deal but in any
case I put nine so blatantly if
you had a time now on the internet it wasn't that
easy difficult yes and and and and that
's just the beginning no and that's why
the learning was just
it is  It's better to
focus on something with all your know-how and go
through with it than just
going around in a diversified way or I'll put it that way, the
other thing is yes,
I've also sold a lot of companies,
of course, well, for people and then
you're with them  continue to be friends with the people
and then there is always
the question afterwards they get a
check I have no idea five million 10
million 20 million 100 million 200
million whatever their share
or the company is worth
and then the question is what do you do  you with
all the money
and then you start
diversifying and investing yes and do
n't invest here and don't
invest there and I have stocks and
I have real estate and precious metals or
in the end you have 100 things and you
have absolutely no idea  more
of what you are doing there and that
somehow doesn't fit ne so the
type of entrepreneur is always highly
focused and value generating and and
if you are an investor then you would have to
be a professional investor ne well
me e.g. I then set myself a rule
I never have
more than 5 shares in my portfolio at any time,
that's an iron rule for me, no,
and I only have real estate
if I somehow need it myself,
so I wouldn't buy anything for myself
and rent it out or something, yes, and
I just try  to keep it extremely simple
and then to focus my resources on
one thing
and that is that, yes, you have to be
extremely careful there, no, every now and then
someone will come by and ask
you for help and then you can
help out with one of them  or can you
come to my negotiating table
or do you still have a buyer here
or something like that
but I would
n't do that at the moment well I say
it's not possible at the moment ne well ah because I
'm basically still busy with Sankt Kilian
and I'm sorry  Yes, just building a family,
no, that also takes a lot of
time and strength and energy and super
nice energy, I don't think
there is anything more beautiful in life and
in the end you can interact well with it, so it's a
Kilian, that's a Kilian  will be a
definitive global brand that of the day
is that we will be one of the top ten whiskey
distilleries in the world, so in terms
of quality and also in terms of know-how, from in
terms of awareness, you have
followed, for example, what
George Clooney has done here now
a few years ago this tequila brand Casa
migos or something like that
there is a playbook where I
think there was summer I do
n't know who the other
fire body was like a buddy and a
third one there were three Hollywood stars yes
and I think that's it  yes, a case I
think there would be a second case,
separate brand again with somehow
yes, for example, there is such a
kickboxer of Irish descent who
made Irish whiskey popular in America, so to speak, and now there are
two guys again who have Hollywood  Stars
they played it so wonderfully vampire uh
series I think Brothers Bond
is their brand they also make a kind of
whiskey they are always Hollywood
stars or movie stars and behind it there is
a big B2B whiskey distillery, so to speak,
which implements it, the
produce is not them themselves  are
basically just a burns ne and uh that's
most comparable in our portfolio with Bud Spencer and Terence Hill mostly
ne but I could
increase that you really watch this one now
if you really want to become national
that you then attack and say
okay, I know somehow because I know the
right name is Ryan Reynolds or
else you could do with Bud
Spencer and Terence Hills always really well
served because of course they are not
only known in Germany but
also in Italy Hungary Europe in general even
in Japan yes  they have a lot of
fans and and that's actually a very, very
good brand and a good start,
okay, that means what wasn't so
easy to do as a German
banker, playing international rollerball,
is definitely easier in whiskey, yes,
no, because you can  just
about this this trick of licensing
and the branding you can there you can
go out there yes what are so so so
whiskey brands that you should know now so
refrain from being
Kilian what the other the the IWC
the Rolex the  I don't know erm the single malt
area is of course the Rolls-Royce
McAllen no where I've grown very, very big
so
if you like peaty whiskeys
for example there are things like artback if
I'm a big fan of it yes
you have then in the blended whiskey area
this is nothing to collect so
to generate value but to enjoy,
for example Johnny Walker yes
you know that
exactly so the red label black label
blue label green label
even
make a song about you already a song
we have already we have already  a
song by the band from Aachen
that's the White Dogs song
coming soon what we're doing yeah um
regular online tastings no we
actually have the biggest online whiskey tasting far and wide that
means every two or three months
we have like a thousand 1500  People who
take part live and in online tasting,
a film team comes here, converts our
distillery into a film studio, we
send out sets beforehand, so tasing
sets with 7 or 8 different whiskeys
that are tasted that
evening and we always invite
stars  one or bands or something like that,
it sometimes happens that
we sing rock songs like that and
he's still small with 1000 1500 people
but you can also watch it on YouTube
and then you'll get it there
too  some uh and great and can
the company
finance itself today or do
you still have to add
no, it can finance itself from itself
but the question is how
much do you want to grow so if you
somehow stop
somewhere very quickly  want to have the next growth spurt
is then you have to finance it,
but basically the thing is
through yes, what kind of output can you
produce here, so if you say
200,000 barrels a year at the moment, so if
you think internationally now, then
you probably just need
more and more material  you need a lot
more well you we have to
increase the production also
expand the plant can already do more so
we can say
twice as much maybe even
triple the production still works no so if
we all use everything
we have  now have here but in order to become a really big
global player then in the end had to
grow it again so
make it bigger no but I would
imagine yes yes absolutely so that is
but that is just that is a
bit of a difference no so in the
adventure area  Do you often have
a three-year training plan? Five
years is a lot, so here in the whiskey
business the business plan is more like 10
to 20 years because the thing simply
has to mature for that long and because we are
also talking about the dimensions that
it needs  just give it time, so you
ca
n't
force internationalization like that overnight, or something like that, it
doesn't work, yes, it works when at
Step there are a lot of classic
distribution channels, exporters,
importers involved, yes, you have to make sure
that you have the taste of the
respective  Country meets that is, there is
already a lot of classic in it, yes, the
special thing about the spirits business is
that the difference
in the startup scene is that
every country has different customs regulations and
a different alcohol tax, i.e.
spirits tax, which means you ca
n’t just do it today  Selling headquarters from
Germany to 20 or 50 countries
that is very, very complicated,
you then need a quasi-full warehouse in the
country of the destination.
Usually only importers have that, so you
always have to go through third parties, otherwise
we’ll be everywhere, yes, but that’s it
In the spirits sector there are
many barriers
to market entry or obstacles
that don't make it so easy,
thank you very much for taking the time to
tell us so openly, um, we will
definitely stay tuned and if you
want to try it out, you can order
what the name of the website is  www ST Kilian
desstillers.com
you can of course also visit us
here, we are 45 minutes from
Frankfurt Airport Frankfurter Kreuz,
so you can get there relatively
quicker and it’s your turn, even if it
’s a bit outback here again, then
you’re sitting here with you in your
whiskey room  and that for 40 € 3 hours to
try every whiskey always feels like
the world is right in this room
and we're going to the
barrel store open a few bottles
yes try them through everything alright
thank you very much ciao ciao
[music  ]